Jerusalem a holy city two three major
religions is just one bone of contention
in the Middle East conflict the border
between Israel and the Palestinian west
bank runs through the city but Israel
claims the whole of Jerusalem for itself
and the Palestinians want East Jerusalem
as the capital of their future state
this is the Western Wall the holiest
site for the Jews but almost equal
numbers of Israelis and Arabs live in
the area the situation throughout the
West Bank is equally complicated more
than 600,000 Israelis live in the
territory spread over hundreds of
official and illegal settlements and the
Israeli settlers keep on building
clearing the settlements would be a
political ordeal for Israel they also
make any potential boundary between
Israel and the West Bank even more
complicated the Palestinians insist on
the borders that existed before the
six-day war in 1967 but by building
border fortifications over the past
decade seen here in yellow Israel has
moved further away from the pre-war
boundaries these walls mainly found in
the West Bank are meant to keep out
bombers from the Palestinian territories
with evidence success because the number
of attacks in Israel has decreased
significantly
the biggest security risk facing Israel
today comes from the gaza strip along
with the West Bank the territory is
intended to be part of the new
Palestinian state but if there are
negotiations who will sit at the other
side of the table in Gaza the radical
Islamic Hamas movement has been in
control since 2007 it regards Israel as
an enemy and rejects peace talks in
contrast to the more moderate Fattah
that governs the West Bank Israelis and
Palestinians are now hoping to take
first steps but neither side thinks a
solution to the Middle East conflict is
likely